[Music]
the games have started
Edgar is The Bard The Bard is sharp we
have a plenty of Plant City fails
he's charming and bikeable
oh God I could kiss you try it
is a barbarian lives to fight foes and
everyone else luckily you can't make her
angry because she's already angry
Simon is a sorcerer master of magic
[Music]
maybe I'm not saying it
is a druid he changes shapes on the
outside
same on the inside
is a paladin a warrior Associates and he
can afford to be polite
heal as well good sir he's interesting
Forge is a rogue trust him once shame on
you keep her safe you have my word trust
him twice I don't want to see him die
which is why I'm Gonna Leave the Room
then we have the red wizard powerful and
ruthless the last face you want to see
and now you are ready to go out you can
see Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves
you must have found a new Den did he eat
the last one
[Music]
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blazer because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
follow me it's the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
she missed
no that's not good
aren't you sick of failing we couldn't
die there's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
now
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
[Music]